[Musik]
[Applaus]
die vorliegenden zahlen lügen nicht und
sie lassen keinerlei raum für zweifel
polen erlebt gerade sein goldenes
zeitalter die beste epoche seiner
gesamten geschichte
seitdem ist im jahr 1989 als erstes
landes warschauer paktes kommt
kommunismus lossagte wurde polen zum
wirtschaftswunderland europas das jahr
1991 ja das ist schon etwas länger her
war das letzte wirklich schlechte jahr
für die polnische wirtschaft bis zur
corona krise und während übrigen europa
viele höhen und tiefen auf dem weg
dorthin gab wuchs die polnische
wirtschaft seit 1992 jedes jahr um
durchschnittlich über vier prozent pro
jahr
weder die asienkrise noch die dotcom
krise noch die finanzkrise noch die
europäische schuldenkrise konnten der
wirtschaftlichen basis polen ist etwas
anhaben und selbst die krone krise
scheint sich hier nur moderat
auszuwirken
polens wirtschaft plötzlich laut iwf
nach der korona krise schnell erholen
genau aus diesem grund liegt das
polnische pro kopf bruttoinlandsprodukt
kaufkraftbereinigt bereits praktisch auf
dem niveau portugals und sehr nahe an
dem spaniens schau dir mal damit du dir
das ausmaß des erfolgs ausmalen kannst
diese kleine grafik an
seit dem fall des kommunismus hat sich
die größe der polnischen wirtschaft
verachtfacht
und nicht nur das bip alle indikatoren
haben sich deutlich verbessert die
exporte stiegen und stiegen jedes jahr
fiel immer wieder rekorde bei der
schaffung neuer arbeitsplätze und die
produktivität der polnischen
arbeitnehmer hat seit 1993 um den faktor
drei zugenommen damit ist polen ein
heißer kandidat darauf so etwas wie das
neue deutschland europas zu werden
eine neue industrie und exporten wer
hätte das 1989 gedacht unter den roten
stiefel man lieben zuschauer zwischen
1940 und 89 das heißt 45 jahre lang
stand polen unter der kontrolle der
sowjetunion während dieser ganzen zeit
konnten die polen weder über die form
ihrer regierung noch über das kritische
wirtschaftliche und soziale modell ihres
landes entscheiden alles absolut alles
wurde ihnen vom kreml über die
kommunistische partei polens die
sogenannte polnischen vereinigten
arbeiterpartei aufgezwungen das musst du
dir aber eines vergegenwärtigen viele
jahrzehnte war der kommunismus in polen
nicht so extrem und totalitär ausgeprägt
wie in vielen anderen ländern westlich
des eisernen vorhangs dafür gab es
mehrere gründe unter anderem
internationalen druck und die tatsache
dass sich die polen als mitteleuropäer
fühlten und daher eine stärkere
zivilgesellschaft am leben erhalten
konnten darüber hinaus hatte die
katholische kirche einen großen einfluss
im land und man könnte sagen dass in
gewisser weise ganz anderen ideen als
denen die aus moskau kam kirchenasyl
gewährt
[Musik]
der springende punkt ist nun dass all
diese faktoren es ermöglichten dass es
in der damaligen polen eine gewisse
opposition gab dass bewegung wenig
soldaten entstanden und dass die
kollektivierung maßnahmen in der
landwirtschaft nicht so extrem aus wie
der polnische staat versuchte sogar sein
glück mit der einführung des sogenannten
konkurrenz sozialismus oder markt
sozialismus dabei handelt es sich um
einen politischen ansatz
marktwirtschaftliche prinzipien auf die
zentrale planwirtschaft anzuwenden ist
natürlich ziemlich in die hose gehen
doch trotz allem trotz eines weniger
radikalen oder totalitären regimes waren
die 70er und 80er jahre auch sehr harte
jahre so politisch als auch
wirtschaftlich neben dem kriegsrecht zum
beispiel lautete der stand anspruch in
1980 er jahren in polen nehmer was zu
deutsch so viel heißt wie es gibt keine
sohn so das war die standard-antwort in
allen geschäften kiosken und zweitens
weil der mangel an den grundlegendsten
produkten so stark kassierte sohn ihm
gesellte sich das schlange stehen vom
volkssport nummer eins die menschen
verbrachten stunden über stunden in
langen schlangen wenn du das gerücht
aufkam eine begehrte ware seien in einem
bestimmten geschäft angekommen und nein
es ging nicht um iphones sondern zum
beispiel um fleisch keine spur von heid
es ist schwierig einen zeugenbericht
über das leben im sozialistischen polen
zu finden der sich nicht genau auf diese
elend langen schlangen bezieht
[Musik]
sie haben sich ins kollektive gedächtnis
fest eingeplant so mangel an waren aller
art den langen warteschlangen und den
relativ häufigen ausfälle der strom- und
wasserversorgung kamen dann noch das
problem steigender inflation
die gegen ende der 80er jahre fast zur
hyperinflation ausflugsboot 45 jahre
nach der einführung des real
existierenden sozialismus nach
sowjetischem vorbild war die polnische
wirtschaft in einem desaströsen zustand
sodass trost dass sie kaum in der lage
war die grundbedürfnisse der eigenen
bevölkerung abzudecken so weit so
schlecht aber jetzt fragst du dich
vielleicht mag wenn das land ende der
80er jahre derart verwahrlost war
wie konnten sich die dinge so schnell
ändern wie schafft er es die polnische
wirtschaft wieder phönix aus der asche
auferstehen und sich zu einem der
größten europäischen wirtschaftsmächte
der letzten 50 jahre aufzuschwingen wie
vollzog sich die transformation vom
kommunismus zum kapitalismus von der
planwirtschaft zur marktwirtschaft genau
das schauen wir uns jetzt mal genauer
die transformation
[Musik]
natürlich war damals nicht nur polen
wirtschaftlich am ende sondern der ganze
kommunistische ostblock inklusive seiner
hegemonialmacht der sowjetunion diese
wirtschaftskrise die immer stärker
werdende opposition und die von michael
gorbatschow vorangetrieben öffnung
gegenüber dem westen führte schließlich
dazu dass alle kommunistischen regime
nach und nach zusammenbrachen und das
polnische war eines der ersten die
voraussetzungen für das neue
kapitalistische system in polen nur
nämlich schon von der kommunistischen
regierung wird ersten reformen in
richtung marktwirtschaft geschafft und
das durchaus mit einigen erfolg denn im
unterschied zu anderen sozialistischen
ländern waren bereits 1988 etwa 20
prozent der unternehmen in privater hand
die polen sammelten so erste tag von der
erfahrung und als unternehmer am ersten
januar 1990 schließlich begann die erste
postkommunistische regierung mit der
umsetzung eines revolutionären reform
plans um das land von oben nach unten zu
verändern wir sprechen hier von einer
der ambitioniertesten und
tiefgreifendsten wirtschaftsreformen die
weltweit umgesetzt wurde ziel war die
umwandlung der immer noch zu 80 prozent
zentralen planwirtschaft bei der alle
produktionsmittel eigentum des staates
sind in einr ein kapitalistisches
marktwirtschaftliches system zu ehren
von leszek balcerowicz stehen damaligen
finanzminister dem architekten und
ideologen dieses radikalen wandels wurde
er als war robert plant bezeichnet
leszek balcerowicz war damals ein junger
42-jähriger wirtschaftswissenschaftler
der an der zentralen schule für planung
und statistik in warschau promoviert
hatte er war als mitglied der mächtigen
polnischen vereinigten arbeiterpartei
bis er sich 1981 entschloss den
kommunisten den rücken zu kehren
während seiner akademischen arbeit hatte
war sehr hoch wahrscheinlich heimlich
werke von mises und hier gelesen die
sich mit dem sozialismus beschäftigt
zumindest hatten sie nach seiner eigenen
aussage sehr großen einfluss auf seine
denkweise und mit hilfe dieser lektüre
begriff er das privateigentum an
produktionsmitteln und freie märkte für
das funktionieren eines rationalen
preissystems und für die effiziente
koordinierung des wirtschaftssystems
unerlässlich sind
[Musik]
darüber hinaus beschäftigte sich was
herr hrubesch auch eingehend mit den
reformen von ludwig erhard dem vater des
deutschen wirtschaftswunders balcerowicz
kräfte all diese fäden zusammen und
machte sich daran polen auch den kopf zu
stellen und siehe da das gelang ihm auch
der erste postkommunistische
ministerpräsident polens tadeusz
mazowiecki wollte az stellt posten des
stellvertretenden ministerpräsidenten
und finanzministern er hoffte damit das
beste deutsche nachkriegs etwas wunder
auch in polen produzieren zu können
er sah darin die einzige möglichkeit
nicht nur der armut zu entkommen und den
wohlstand wieder zu gewinnen sondern
auch die junge demokratie polens zu
retten
wir stehen vor einer dramatischen
alternative entweder wir setzen den weg
hin zu einer besseren wirtschaft fort
oder wir gehen alle bereits erreichten
errungenschaften auf und kehrt ins chaos
zurück leszek balcerowicz im plädoyer
für seinen reformplan vor dem polnischen
parlament
erinnern wir uns daran dass der
zusammenbruch der kommunistischen
systeme damals zunächst zu einer noch
größeren wirtschaftlichen krise führte
dann innerhalb von nur zwei jahre nach
der politischen wende brach die
industrieproduktion in polen um fast 40
prozent ein
fast 1,5 millionen menschen hatten ihren
arbeitsplatz verloren und es drohte eine
hyperinflation wie genau also
serviceplan aus der polin aus dieser
ganzen misere retten sollte
am 6 oktober 1989 wurde er dem volk im
fernsehen vorgestellt und im dezember
wurde auf seiner grundlage im parlament
ein umfassendes paket von 11 gesetzen
verabschiedet das die geschichte polens
immer verändern sollte
diese gesetze gegen sehr viele
verschiedene dinge auf einmal an das
erste gesetz schreibt vor dass alle
stars unternehmen nach
marktwirtschaftlichen kriterien zu
führen waren und man höre und staune im
falle ihrer überschuldung konkurs
anmelden konnten das zweite gesetz
untersagt der zentralbank die
finanzierung des staatsdefizits und
scheint er die schaffung neuen geldes
stark beine
mit anderen worten es tag bei der
staatlichen gelddruckmaschine gewaltig
auf die bremse es folgt nun das gesetz
über kredite und das gesetz über die
beschränkung übermässiger lohnerhöhungen
sie beseitigten die privilegien
öffentliche unternehmen kredite zu
erhalten und deckelten das übermäßige
wachstum der löhne und gehälter im
öffentlichen sektor und in staatsfirmen
auch im rahmen neuer zoll und
steuergesetze wurden alle privilegien
die öffentlichen unternehmen gegenüber
privatfirmen hatten abgeschafft
ebenfalls fast vollständig liberalisiert
wurden ausländische direktinvestitionen
importe exporte die rückführung von
gewinnen an ausländische
muttergesellschaft mit eigentlich
jeglicher kapital zu und abfluss sowie
die umrechnung des wechselkurses des
zloty zu ausländischen währungen
[Musik]
hinzu kam staatliche preiskontrollen
wurden komplett abgeschafft ebenso mobil
viele subventionen die der staat über
als deutlich verteilt hatte der
arbeitsmarkt wurde tags mobilisiert und
ausländischen investoren wurde eine 100
prozentige garantie ihrer investitionen
im falle einer enteignung gegeben aber
das war noch nicht alles der größte und
schwerste teil des programms war nämlich
der plan zur privatisierung staatlicher
unternehmen sowie großer weiterer teile
bestand eigentums und all dies wurde
praktisch über nacht in daran gesetzt
und obwohl es vielleicht überraschend
klingt als diese maßnahmen fanden in der
bevölkerung eine starke und breite
unterstützung obwohl klar war dass die
für viele zunächst mit enormen
nachteilen verbunden sein würden die
polen hatten einfach deckt
überwältigenden eindruck dass das
einzige was zwischen ihnen und den
wohlstand nach westlichem vorbild stand
das sozialistisch kommunistisches system
war
und je schneller ist abgeschafft und das
heißt würde desto besser für alle alles
in butter also man musste nur diese paar
schalter umlegen und schon würde der
wohlstand für alle daherkommen wie
fliegende brathähnchen aus dem
schlaraffenland nein ganz und gar nicht
zunächst lag eine mammut-aufgabe
ungeheuren ausmaßes vor polen und ihr
ausgang war alles andere als gewiss denn
wie anderen sozialistischen
volkswirtschaften drohte auch die
polnische hauptsächlich auf riesigen
staatskonzernen einmal noch größer als
der andere stark aufgebläht und
hochgradig unrentabel ohne
überlebenschancen in einer freien
marktwirtschaft wenn man diese großen
stürme nun einfach alle der zerstörung
preisgeben würde käme eine unbewältigte
soziale krise auf die polnische
gesellschaft zu je länger man sie jedoch
am leben liest desto stärker würde man
die wachstumschancen agiler und wetten
dass wege unternehmen abwürgen und einen
raschen aufschwung aufs spiel setzen
wie soll er die polnische regierung
dieses paradoxon nur lösen das sehen wir
uns jetzt mal genauer an
die staatlichen kolosse
[Musik]
eine sache dürftet ihr wird klar sein
auch wenn ab 1988 zaghafte versuche
einer liberalisierung zu sehen waren war
noch 89 die polnische wirtschaft was
noch vollständig von staatsunternehmen
dominiert wir sprechen also noch immer
von einer knallharten zentralistischen
planwirtschaft sozialistischen gerade
deshalb waren die meisten ökonomen
damals der ansicht dass der
entscheidende schritt zur transformation
dieser länder die umgestaltung des
öffentlichen sektors sein würde
nur so könne man die notwendigen
ressourcen freisetzen und einer
effizienteren allokation zu führen und
wie du sicher weist haben staatsfirmen
in der regel viele probleme
sie sind träge äußerst arm an
leistungsanreize haben sehr ineffiziente
kostenstruktur keinen echten rendite und
müssen sich in der regel kaum darum
scheren ob sie ihre guten wirklich
zufriedenstellen sie werden viel geld
mit nur geringen gegenwert aus dem
fenster in dem sie zum beispiel teure
versorgungsposten für aus liebe
politiker und parteikader finanzieren
müssen ein paradebeispiel dafür waren
die großen polnischen werften die
polnischen werften wurden von zentralen
planungsbehörden kontrolliert sie hatten
keinen globalen ansatz so dass jeder
werft alle arten von schiffen baute
damit sie irgendwie ausgelastet war
mit anderen worten sie mussten sich
nicht spezialisieren und waren
entsprechend ineffizient außerdem hatten
sie sehr überhöhte kostenstrukturen und
vielen mehr mitarbeiter als sie
tatsächlich benötigt
[Musik]
neben den bereits erwähnten versorgungs
präsentieren auch aus sozialen gründen
denn der sozialismus versprach
vollbeschäftigung koste es was es wolle
im ergebnis waren sie damit nicht nur
einfache welt verbrennungsmaschine nein
sie waren wahre hoch bösen in dem der
staat das volksvermögen in einem
atemberaubenden tempo verbrannt ihr
eigentlich ist business modell brote und
marginal auf den verkauf von schiffen
vielmehr jedoch auf der entgegennahme
staatliche kommission das problem ist
natürlich dass es schwierig ist ein
derartig schwerfälliges schiff zu wenden
die werft manager waren es gewohnt mit
staatlichen bürokraten zu verhandeln
nicht mit kunden die schiffe brauchten
sie besaßen kaum noch im normalen
wettbewerb auf dem schiffsmarkt mit
anderen werften konkurrieren zu können
und aufträge an land zu ziehen
außerdem befand sich die produktivität
an einen absoluten tiefpunkt tatsächlich
lag sie bei weniger als einem viertel
der produktivität von werken in anderen
ländern wie südkorea japan oder sogar
china allerdings waren die polnischen
ersten so unrentable sie aus
wirtschaftlicher sicht war die
entwicklung polens aus ganz anderer
sicht unglaublich wichtig sie waren die
keimzellen und einer der wichtigsten
motoren der demokratisierung polen die
arbeiter der danziger lenin werft zum
beispiel galten schon immer als
aufmüpfig und eigensinnig schon seit den
siebziger jahren protestierten sie durch
egal streiks und arbeitsniederlegungen
gegen die totalitäre staat macht und sie
schreckten auch nicht zurück als diese
ihre streiks blutig niederschlug
streikkomitees der danziger werft zu
denen auch der elektriker und spätere
demokratisch gerät das den puls lexar
gehört er gründete im jahr 1980 die
gewerkschaft solidarnosc und zwangen den
staat zu zugeständnissen
dh die neue demokratische regierung
baden arbeitern der dürften durchaus
politisch verbunden sie schickte daher
verhalten einstellungen wandelte die
werk zwar in eine aktiengesellschaft um
an der die mitarbeiter maßgeblich
beteiligt wurden hielt jedoch viele
subventionen weiter so und jetzt kommt
die große überraschung all das war
entgegen der einschätzung der damaligen
ökonomen und analysten in der
übergangsphase quasi vollkommen
irrelevant denn durch die reformen des
wassers wurde im privatsektor eine
solche dynamik entfesselt dass alle
tretkraft des wandels aus den vielen
neuen kleinen und mittleren unternehmen
kam die plötzlich die pilze aus dem
boden schossen
während die umstrukturierung und
privatisierung der großen öffentlichen
bekannten also langsam vorankamen nahm
die neue privatwirtschaft um 42 auf das
1994 bereits 102 millionen private
unternehmen und betriebe für fast die
hälfte aller nichtlandwirtschaftlichen
arbeitsplätze im land verantwortliche
hand und es ist so sicher darauf
gespannt zu welchen konkreten
ergebnissen dieses in polen führte nun
die ergebnisse sind eindeutig also
aufgepasst die ergebnisse
ausgezeichnet hervorragend herausragend
was polen für seinen wirtschaftlichen
transformationsprozess verdient ist
eindeutig die bestnote
wie sich nämlich herausstellte war die
krise infolge des modellwechsels nur
sehr kurzlebig trotz des zusammenbruchs
was aller staatlichen institutionen
hatte sich das bip in knapp sechs jahren
bereits vollständig erholt und dann
begann in polen eine periode
ununterbrochenen wachstums welches nach
was 30 jahre nur leicht durch die korona
krise gebremst wurde 1999 lag das bip
polens bereits 20 prozent höher
als 1989 und die wirtschaftstätigkeit
schoss in die höhe und es ging nicht nur
um geschäftliche aktivität an sich ein
riesiger strom aus leidiger
direktinvestitionen oder in gang gesetzt
im jahr 98 beispielsweise entfielen auf
polen nicht weniger als 40 prozent aller
ausländischen direktinvestitionen ströme
in mittel und osteuropa so mein leben
freunde begann also die
erfolgsgeschichte polens das heute 30
jahre später mit ländern wie portugal
oder sogar spanien gleich zieht und
ihrem einem bald überholen sagt wie
diese art schocktherapie über nacht
überwand polen den kommunismus und die
reformen wurden im laufe der jahre noch
fortgesetzt zb umfassende
gesundheitsreform mit einführung des
auch in deutschland geltenden business
systems kostenfreie
gesundheitsversorgung wurde 1999 durch
einen beitrag sein ganzes system ersetzt
und wettbewerb durch private anbieter
ermöglicht auch das 1 1 system wurde
vollständig informiert und
kapitalbildung elemente eingeführt
im falle polens ist auch auffällig dass
keine regierung die max freundlichen
reformen ihrer vorgänger rückgängig
gemacht hat damit widerlegt polen eine
verurteilt das demokratischer wechsel
nicht mit wirtschaftlicher kontinuität
vereinbar sei so und jetzt wo wir einen
kleinen überblick gegeben haben bist du
an der reihe
was hältst du von solch abdruckten
veränderungen glaubst du dass das
polnische model in gewisser weise als
vorbild für andere länder mit ähnlichen
problemen dienen könnte schreibt uns
alles was ihr einfällt was kommentar
unter dieses video in dem er auf diese
schon hochgradig gespannt ich hoffe dass
wir dieses video gefallen und vielleicht
auch etwas gebracht hat was ja gib uns
bitte einen daumen hoch und unterstütze
uns in denen du bist mit deinem freund
heißt und vergesst bitte nicht dass wir
jede woche neue videos hochladen
abonnieren
kanal blick auf das links wohnung
rechtzeitig benachrichtigt zu werden was
gut und bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]
[Applaus]